not much of a loser I am maybe because
I'm drunk I'm gonna say it again my very
first girlfriend like we got to this
huge fight we're doing long distance I
was going to Riverside she was going to
Davis I knew we weren't compatible so
one day it was like 4 a.m and we're just
like are you on the phone I was like you
know what we don't
actually went dead silence she hung up
the phone she ghosted me for like two
weeks oh two weeks before I was going
back to Sacramento to see her you see
them in the facial expression it's
different like they moved on or some
[__] no warm no no nothing you
cold-hearted [__]
say that we're not gonna beat again
anymore and I'll show you how I react
we're ready
what for real I grabbed this bitch's
ankles
you're the one that said that you're not
compatible I know I regret it Joe
Bro that was one of the biggest life
lessons for me because I realized I was
such a [__] loser shout outs to her
she was great man I miss her so much she
had a fat ass
you're not compatible